[upbeat jazz music]
♪
- SO, GIG,
SHOULD WE STRETCH FIRST?
- NO, LET'S JUST, YOU KNOW,
STAY TIGHT AND GET INJURED.
- CHECK IT OUT.
LEW ALCINDOR.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
- THAT JUST--
SOMETHING JUST TWEAKED--
A LITTLE SOMETHING--REAL BAD.
- I LIKE TO ROTATE
UNTIL THE PAIN SPREADS
AND IT'S MORE OF A NUMB--
NUMB EVERYWHERE KIND OF THING.
- THERE IT IS!
YOU KNOW, IT'S NICE TO SEE
HOW SORT OF
LOOPY AND WEIRD
YOUR ARMS ARE.
- I'VE GOT REAL NOODLE ARMS
THESE DAYS.
- [chuckling]
- THAT'S RIGHT!
I WAS LIKE "YO, BOO!
WHAT'S UP WITH THAT ASS,
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?"
LET'S GET IT UP, GET IT UP!
- YOU GUYS ARE REALLY BLACK.
FREAKIN' COMMODORES.
- AHH!
THAT'S MY BALL!
IT'S A LITTLE FLAT, BUT--
- GET THAT BALL OUTTA HERE, YO.
LET'S CHOOSE IT UP.
WE GOT TWO AND FOUR.
WE GOT SIX.
- I'LL SERVE.
IF YOU GUYS JUST
WANNA HANG OUT.
- WHAT YOU TALKING ABOUT, YO?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- LET'S CHOOSE TEAMS UP, BABY.
LET'S CHOOSE TEAMS UP.
- I GOT MY MAN RIGHT HERE.
- MIKE-MIKE BE BALLIN'!
MIKE-MIKE!
LET ME SEE WHO I WANT.
JJ!
WHOOPTY-WHOO!
BOO! YOU KNOW
HOW TO DO IT, JJ.
- WE COME AS A PAIR.
- I'LL GET THIS BOB BARKER,
RON PAUL LOOKIN' DUDE
RIGHT HERE.
- DAMN. YOU BE RIGHT ON THE
BUTTON WITH THESE FOOLS, MAN.
BUT, SISTER, GIMME
JUDI DENCH UP IN HERE.
YOU KNOW WHO JUDI DENCH IS,
RIGHT?
[hysterical laughter]
- ALL RIGHT, DAME JUDI DENCH
READY TO SHOOT SOME HOOPS.
- BALL UP, BALL UP!
- I'LL SCRATCH YOU UP.
- ALL RIGHT.
- OH!
- OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
- GET OVER HERE, Y'ALL.
COME ON, MAN.
- FIRST OFF...
O.J. DID IT, ALL RIGHT?
- YOU KNOW, MY ANALYST SAYS
THAT IF I DON'T GET OUT
AND PLAY MORE,
THAT, UH, I'M NEVER GONNA GET
BACK IN THE GAME, PROBABLY.
- I'M GONNA BE HONEST
WITH YOU, MAN.
- UH-HUH.
- YOU TERRIBLE.
- NOW MY BOY, GIL--
THAT GUY IS NO GOOD.
I COULD REALLY
LAY HIM OUT QUICKLY.
WITH HIM OUT OF THE WAY,
I THINK WE'RE JUST GONNA BE...
360 SPINS AND SLAM DUNK
POINTERS.
- DUDE.
- TAKE YOUR HANDS OFF ME.
I'M NOT ONE OF YOUR STUDENTS.
- OH, I PUT A LOT MORE THAN
MY HANDS INSIDE MY STUDENTS.
- OH! GET OFF OF ME!
[chewing sounds]
[bone pops]
OW!
- OH! SNAP!
- YOU POPPED MY SHOULDER.
- AND RON PAUL JUST BROKE
PHIL SPECTOR'S SHOULDER, YO.
- MY FRIEND HAS
A POPPED SHOULDER.
PLEASE GIVE ME
A BURNT BAGEL FOR ME.